hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my agents of shield episode 15
video careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen it yet there are a couple
pretty big Easter eggs some of them a
little bit weirder than others there was
also something really cool I spotted in
the teaser for the next episode that
I'll talk about at the end of the video
because it's hive related the ward
character is the hive of the comics thus
far the way they portrayed him has been
very traditional like in terms of what
you would expect from a TV show special
effects are getting better and better on
TV shows the flash has great special
effects agents of shield has access to a
lot of the things that they use to make
effects for the movies so it makes it a
little bit easier for them to do super
cool stuff when they really want to and
I always give a comic book show props
when they try to do something that's
very comic-book accurate even if it
doesn't totally work out Deathlok is a
good example of something that's really
awesome in the comics that didn't quite
end up being as cool as I hoped it had
been on the TV show but all the hive
related stuff i've seen has been a plus
so let's do top 5 WTF and I'll do Easter
eggs as we go along
number 5 charlie bit my finger that's
all I could think about when they
revealed the Inhumans name my name is
Charlie I'm homeless I give you special
visions of the future that drive you mad
takes a little while to learn his
backstory but the whole conceit is
should they try to avoid what his
visions show them should they lean into
the fourth dimension as fit starts
talking about it Fitz explaining the
fourth dimension was also a lot of fun I
don't know if I even understand this but
number four WTF hive is now like a
full-on Bond villain them sitting over
dinner being polite to each other just
felt like something that a Bond villain
would do the true power line nice Easter
Egg for Avengers looking Nick Fury let
me know if real power wants a magazine
or something
number three WTF Daisy's vision she
hallucinates things going to complete
and that serves as the backbone of
the plot they're gonna try and rescue
Charlie but they're gonna try and do it
in a way that doesn't get them killed
he's a very familiar story line fits his
explanation just like I said you know
the fourth dimension you can't avoid it
we're inside the cube the cube is
unchangeable making you think a little
bit about the tesseract I guess but they
are right and usually people
misinterpret visions as you kind of see
later in the episode
Coulson shooting Daisy turned out to be
heard seeing Coulson shoot the mirror
she just saw herself being shot in the
reflection so they just derped misread
the vision it's a very common thing as
if your Big Game of Thrones fans
Melisandre has visions in the books
people think they're really important
because Melisandre is an important
character but some of them are
misinterpreted visions the real test for
changing the future would be using the
time gem I cannot wait for Doctor
Strange if they really do end up putting
the time gem in that movie the way Kevin
Feige is talked he's talked about Doctor
Strange altering probabilities makes it
sound like he'll be using the time gem
but that's something else altogether
number two WTF Malick gets the Kraken
suit I'm gonna assume that this is the
Kraken suit from the comics Kraken is an
alias used by a couple different people
that wear a special suit of armor now in
the comics it's kind of like an organic
Iron Man suit it has a certain level of
intelligence to it the last character in
the comics to wear it was Nick Fury's
brother if you guys didn't know Nick
Fury has a brother in the comics he
wears the suit and uses it to start a
civil war inside Hydra which makes me
wonder because of Malik's vision at the
end maybe he saw what hive is going to
do his pants and he's having second
thoughts now so maybe he might help
Coulson down the road Malick was pretty
evil to begin with but they kind of did
the Anakin Skywalker Darth Vader scene
where he's like kill him prove that
you're not afraid like when the Emperor
was trying to get Anakin to kill Count
Dooku and he did so Malick has now fully
gone to the dark side although he was
really evil to begin with so I feel like
the Star Wars metaphor doesn't hold up
quite as well as it should the company
that made that exoskeleton transia is
actually the same name as the hometown
of Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch in the
comics at least in the 60s comics they
might have changed it since then but at
any time you hear a weird name on a
Marvel TV show it's probably an Easter
Egg for something in the comics but in
this case it's not a company it's a
place in the place just happens to be
the hometown of Quicksilver and Scarlet
Witch number one WTF though was the
teaser for next week's episode where
hive says I'm going to show you my true
self and you just get a peak of the
tentacle head this is what hive looks
like in the comics they totally did it
for the TV show I can't imagine how
expensive it must have been to do those
special effects but it's gonna look
really badass small aside we also have
to mention the lash Mei stuff I was
never really down with their chemistry I
never felt like those two characters had
chemistry but it actually this scene
between the
in this episode totally worked for me
but his storyline kind of tied in with
what Lincoln was saying during the
episode Inhumans were made to fill a
need lash felt like this was the place
that he needed to be in this moment so
the episode is kind of telling you
through the stuff that Daisy Lincoln
lash we're saying as well as Fitz his
explanation of the fourth dimension that
you can escape destiny things are meant
to play out a certain way and then they
pan to that scene of the Quinjet in
space with the dead SHIELD agent and
it's kind of like the arrow grave scene
where they want to tease a character
dying but they slowly reveal who it is
over a series of episodes the first time
we saw it was right before we met the
slingshot character and because her
cross is floating here in space right
now I feel like she's the dead person
inside the Quinjet but you guys can let
me know who's this dead character and do
you think that they're doing the same
thing that arrow is doing this season
teasing that a character is going to die
and it's gonna be a really big WTF death
side note if you guys are watching arrow
they're actually gonna reveal who's that
on that show tomorrow justjust for arrow
and not for agents of shield but what
I'm gonna do next because the flash is
on break I'm gonna do a flash bonus
video there's some stuff that ties in
with the big WTF death for arrow
tomorrow it gets kind of complicated so
I'll try to find an easy way to do it
but be sure to subscribe to get that
flash bonus video new episode of arrow
tomorrow you know there's any other
Marvel videos that you guys want me to
do just let me know in the comments if
you guys haven't seen I just posted a
couple big Marvel movie videos you can
click here for my Captain America vs
Black Panther video and you can click
here for my Doctor Strange behind the
scenes video thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you